très bien Ray, très bien, tu es prêt,
beaucoup de personnes neurodivergentes ont
été surtraitées, c'est un
endroit où elles peuvent venir, tu n'as pas à
t'inquiéter, tu sais qu'elles doivent le faire de
cette façon, de cette façon,
c'est une libération, c'est un examen physique.
libération mentale et émotionnelle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont affaire à une société qui
n'est pas nécessairement adaptée à ça, donc
j'appelle ça une révolution d'évolution
[Musique]
merci [
Musique]
scintille,
c'est
maintenant préparez-vous pour votre deuxième fois à
l'étranger,
ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien sûr, il y a des moments où je me sens
dépassé et juste fatigué, vous savez, alors
j'essaie juste de me rappeler que je ne suis pas
seul,
c'est que
vous savez quand vous pensez que quelque chose ne va pas
mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment sûr et  vous pourriez
être un peu dans le déni,
il n'était pas
certain des jalons, c'est
vrai,
il ne parlait pas, il n'établissait pas de contact visuel, on lui
a diagnostiqué un
spectre autistique
quand il avait environ deux ans et demi,
pouvez-vous m'aider
[Musique] aider
moi
non maman
oh wow
tu ne me frappes pas tu frappes ce look
tu vas frapper la boxe le sac de boxe
regarde
va frapper le sac de boxe va frapper le
sac de boxe ouais tu devrais mettre tes
gants pour le faire non d'accord tu ne le fais pas  tu
n'aimes pas mettre les gants tu n'aimes pas les
gants
quand Rey a été diagnostiqué ils ont dit qu'il faisait une
recherche sensorielle il aimait le bruit
de la porte qui claque est-ce que tu aimes ça je
pense que c'est tellement drôle tu penses que c'est tellement
drôle il est très susceptible  il
adore les miroirs, il aimait être poussé, cela
lui fait du bien et cela le
centre aussi, ainsi que certains parents, qui ne
veulent pas que leurs enfants soient étiquetés
et je ne le vois pas comme ça, je vois comme l'
étiqueter comme tu veux.
[Musique]
Je m'en fiche, appelez-le comme vous voulez
tant qu'il obtient les
ressources dont il a besoin si cela signifie
être dans une salle de classe plus petite, cela signifie
suivre une ergothérapie, une
orthophonie, peu importe, peu importe
[Musique]
ouais, le  la caméra doit voir ça c'est une
super chanson
très bien prêt
hé tu vas vouloir l'attraper tu
peux euh dire tu peux je
dis que
tu ne peux pas dire wow
[Musique]
euh je suis la mère d'Oliver euh il a huit
ans
euh il a été diagnostiqué quand  il avait probablement
quatre ans, vous savez, nous avons un jumeau, il est jumeau
euh
et euh ouais, ça a été une
aventure,
bon travail Bobby,
merci mesdames et messieurs, c'était un
spectacle agréable ce soir ouais,
il a quelque chose de spécial
qu'il a et qui le connecte  avec
les gens
euh je pense que sa douceur innocente
aussi ok mon pote Jessica dis-le dans
tes yeux pousse ouais ouais je pense euh ouais
et son humour je veux dire c'est définitivement
il nous fait rire tout le temps j'aime
lutter avec lui
je suis normalement celui qui gagne  même s'il
va à la boxe,
ce que je suis gagne, la raison
pour laquelle je l'ai même inscrit, c'est parce qu'il
était vraiment doué pour battre son
frère comme aujourd'hui, quelqu'un demande
ce qu'est l'autisme, l'autisme ressemble à quelque chose
quand comme vous voyez comme  ça,
j'explique beaucoup mais si tout
cela n'expliquait pas grand-chose
parce qu'il aurait envie de regarder autour de lui, il est
comme s'il l'aimait, il ne sait même pas
que tu es là, comme si tu étais
là, mais il  c'est en quelque sorte
une bonne façon de l'expliquer merci tu
joues juste c'est ta classe
euh ouais c'est vraiment bien mon pote je suis
vraiment fier de toi il sait ce qu'il
fait mais il ne sait pas non plus ouais
ce que je sais ce que je fais  beaucoup et
parfois je n'ai pas raison donc c'est
quelque chose que nous avons en commun,
c'est une chose
et nous aimons aussi les animaux, c'est autre
chose
[Applaudissements]
mais parfois quand il danse, il
a envie de me frapper hé je vais arrêter
Ollie qui ne danse pas
oh
[  Applaudissements]
ok
allez Cassius
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
[Musique]
Je sais que vous jouez mais vous êtes toujours
prêts
[Musique] ok non non
non vous savez pourquoi parce qu'après ils
doivent le nettoyer et ces gars pour qui ils
travaillent très dur  nettoyez le verre alors
ne mettez pas votre bouche là oh ne
vous frappez pas, ce n'est pas grave
vous n'avez pas de problèmes, ne recommencez pas
les enfants du Spectrum,
je pense qu'il y a comme un dicton vous savez que
je suis autiste, soyez patient
ok
s'il le frappe
[Musique]
pour le regarder mais aussi je comprends qu'il est juste
frustré c'est comme si tu lui parlais une
langue différente c'est à ça que
ressemble l'autisme c'est comme ok et bien
si tu es en colère, ne te frappe pas
c'est comme  va frapper ce sac de boxe juste
là, tu sais,
la première fois que je l'ai emmené, nous sommes entrés
et je te jure qu'il avait juste l'air et c'est comme si ses
yeux étaient illuminés
et c'était presque comme si j'avais enfin
trouvé un endroit aussi bruyant et  il se passe beaucoup de choses
je ne veux pas dire fou mais
tu sais comme moi tu
connais ce sentiment où tu es comme
wow
deux coups de poing de ce côté
[Musique]
ça augmente la concentration ça réduit l'anxiété en
découvrant aussi qu'ils ont une certaine
puissance physique
allez,
vous m'avez vu boxer là-bas, qu'est-ce que je
pense que je fais cette vieille nana venant
ici il y a même des années, vous savez, j'ai en fait
eu quelques mouvements
mais pour le moment, c'est à propos d'eux, nous
allons faire des rafales
maintenant je suis  Je vais donner aux enfants une chance de
m'entraîner ensuite parce que cela montre à quel
point ils savent réellement quand ils
parviennent à tenir les tricots et à
m'entraîner afin que je puisse l'essayer avec Ray Win. Je
ne sais pas s'il est prêt pour ça, n'est-
ce pas ?  tiens-les pour moi, d'
accord, je vais les frapper, tiens-les
pour moi, tiens-les
là, tu fais un deux un deux oui, d'
accord, tu me dis que tu es le patron,
d'accord
pour moi, c'est toute une vie parce que j'ai  je l'ai vécu, je l'ai compris,
tu fais un excellent
travail, tu veux essayer de le refaire avec moi,
tu penses que je peux le faire,
ouais, d'accord, c'est bon,
j'implore tout le monde d'
écouter différemment, ne t'attends pas à ce qu'ils
soient neurotypiques.  voici un exercice qui peut
t'apprendre quoi faire quand tu es
assommé ça s'appelle qu'est-
ce que tu fais mec
J'aime les lunettes aujourd'hui ce
sont des lunettes 3D qu'on obtient d'un
film L'insistance je les porte
ces derniers temps le fait qu'il  va là-bas il est
salut Amy salut ça salut ça je pense que ça l'a
aidé socialement oui
[Musique]
ils lui permettent il portait souvent beaucoup de
costumes y aller
ça lui a permis de s'exprimer parce
qu'on ne peut pas vraiment communiquer autant qu'il
le voudrait  c'est sa façon de faire,
quel que soit l'isolement que les gens pensent que quelqu'un
qui est neurodivergent vit,
ne présumez pas aussi
vite que les autres enfants que j'ai déjà
formés, alors faites
tout bien, qu'est-ce que nous choisissons, bon travail en
disant s'il vous plaît, récupérez votre argent wow
dis merci merci
ouais ouais
continue de te concentrer sur le bien partout où tu
peux continuer à être toi c'est bon tu as le
droit d'être parfait être parfaitement
imparfait peu importe quelqu'un qui va
t'accepter qui est chaleureux continue d'aller
là où il fait chaud continue de trouver ça
d'accord prends  tes gants pour moi ok
il est heureux clairement tu vois à quel point il est heureux
tu sais je suis reconnaissant de l'avoir
point final
je sais que nous sommes sur la bonne voie
[Musique]